el funeral por dante wright del joven
afroamericano de 20 años que murió por
un disparo por un agente de policía de
brookings entrar en mineápolis ha
servido para volver a pedir justicia por
su memoria pero también para evidenciar
otra vez el grave problema que hay con
la violencia racial en el país el
servicio ha acaparado la atención
mediática en una semana en el que se ha
conocido la sentencia contra derecho vil
que fue declarado culpable el martes de
los tres cargos por asesinato y
homicidio a los que se enfrentaba por la
muerte de georg floyd el abogado y
defensor de derechos civiles ven gran
que ha liderado en las últimas causas de
muertes de afroamericanos a manos de la
policía incluyendo la de floyd y ahora
la de wright ha exigido a los
legisladores del país impulsar una nueva
reforma policial para que este tipo de
casos no se vuelvan a repetir
cientos de personas se han congregado en
esta iglesia de minneapolis para darle
el último adiós a dante wright por ese
expreso de la familia ningún policía
vestido de uniforme ha hecho acto de
presencia y la seguridad se ha
coordinado con voluntarios
al funeral han asistido el gobernador de
minnesota tim walls y la senadora amy
klobuchar ambos se han posicionado a
favor de una reforma policial cuanto
antes y ahora se abre un nuevo proceso
judicial contra la ex policía quin
potter que renunció tras este incidente
en mineápolis la mujer se enfrenta a un
cargo por homicidio involuntario pero
muchos aquí confían en que el veredicto
sirva de ejemplo y ella también pague
por sus actos